well sweetie it already was gonna tell
you I do you Anna laughs I should you
know even enough like how do I start it
how do I started saying so my pops mmm
let me stop my dad boy whose parents are
dead and was it dad's parents are dead
dad died when he was like two or three
mmm my pops actually seven actually
yeah like dad died when he was like two
or three maybe a bit older mmm monday
rain is 15 [ __ ] fam long peak so my mind
grew up with his stepdad and his step
sisters and brothers and [ __ ] like that
and his brother and his real brother as
well yeah so my dad is both from
Trinidad and Grenada okay so basically
they go on holiday to quit out of every
year in it yeah I'm like yeah they know
okay so my dad messaged me
yeah you last night randomly out of the
blue a man said so he messaged me last
night and said so to me and my brother
yeah yeah
man said just to drop a family bomb on
you boys there's a man who in Grenada
that I've met that claims with some
evidence that he's my genetic father
excuse me he claims he claims the [ __ ]
brav
no one could drop that I'm a 50 year old
man you can't drop that on me
bro my dad's 53 you can't drop that on
me just on a on a on a whim and then he
sent me this picture of from 8 ancient
times ago above proverbs no of my nan I
don't already know man
looks like four pictures and this my man
that he's met
okay milk smooth though fam is saucy pic
smooth it's a saucy pic mood I like it I
like who I'm seeing
that's hilarious so yeah so my man takes
me that and I'm like how the [ __ ] yeah
so basically he's always said that he
doesn't like he's never ready to step
that in it yeah he had to live with his
dick so he must have though the guy the
guy said yeah that obviously the guy
that says his dad said like I said how
how like when you say you've met him now
what did you just bump it off secret is
a small island did you bump into him I'm
thinking I looks like me or whatever
yeah and then my man said now he
contacted my dad's sister stepsisters
but how do you even ma'am
this is where the plot thickens this is
where the plot thickens so my man yeah
must have messaged the sisters whatever
whatever whatever yeah and then I was
like cool like how the [ __ ] did he even
know who they are because they're not
related to him then my dad stepsisters
mm-hmm so how does he know to continue
man said apparently my nan yeah my dad
stepdad you're intending to tell my dad
when he turned 18 she died when he was
15 the step dad never told him and
apparently he used to take him on
weekends when my dad was a you yeah
so the might that the real dad used to
come to England take I don't know if he
lived in England wherever he used to
take my dad for the weekend whenever he
was like a kid yeah it was no
recollection if it has no recollection
but he's now met his half-sisters and he
remembers playing with them when he was
a little kid no fam they said he was
some uncle no what bruv what rough what
what that's why all this figure out is
why old you just take just what's at me
like it's like is Willie merely like his
Sunday seem like it's Sunday News what's
that's so random it's a stream random
it's extremely [ __ ] random so yeah do
you know what that means as well no well
it's my granddad that's dead isn't that
is he your granddad he's in my granddad
so easy he's James don't confirm that's
who he is that's his name that's why I'm
named James Duncan come again the guy
that's dead yeah I thought was my
granddad yeah was called James Duncan
[ __ ] hence why my name is James Duncan
[ __ ] this is this is all over the place
so you're named after some guy I'm named
after luckily there's a thread of
happiness which he's he is my uncle's
dad the guy that's dead is my uncle's
dad okay no my dad's dad okay okay yeah
so my dad and his brothers were
half-brothers mm-hmm and he thought they
were full mm-hmm
my uncle's called David David don't go
ever mm-hmm that's his real name
I'm so fine mm-hmm James Duncan who's
that guy that died when my dad was three
or four mm-hmm as my uncle's daddy's
home my granddad the [ __ ] your
granddad's alive what so Duncan's
Technic is my name but it does it's not
nothing to do with me so what's my man's
name thank god he's thank god it went
away I just quote you're not Duncan I am
but I'm not you are but you're not
yeah obviously names are just made up
anyway but I'm not true his name is
Solomon his name is Solomon Forsythe he
was a slave family Forsythe like Bruce
exactly like Bruce exactly i Bruce
barb that's his name copped him that
slave name Oh 100% Forsyte Solomon
Forsyth hmm indeed Wow
so well welcome for your pops not like
what's what's happening I don't know
my dad is vague from I had to drag that
information out of him he went to leave
it with the pic and that I don't think
my dad is I don't think my dad is
looking to check for it of course he's
lived his life thumb he's in his 50s I'm
not checking anything I'm not checking
anything I'm a Duncan I'm not forced
life as a James Forsythe I would never
get laid never get laid have to change a
surname
I'd have to move to Grenada it's one of
moved to Grenada and they've lavish
doesn't like eat or change my name
there's only two up lavish as a like
Forsythe na Solomon for sight before I
can say with confidence no again
that's hilarious it's mad that's
actually hilarious Forsythe Wow
that's the story isn't it welcome to
shit's and gigs that's the story that's
the story bro [ __ ] lovely that was my
last night slash this morning all the
information about the stepdad and
weekend I found that on the way here
today Jesus mmm [ __ ] what is life brah
it's crazy
so yeah G that was that hmm I don't if I
can top that you know you don't need to
top it we're just talking Jesus Solomon
Solomon Forsyth G mmm-hmm Wow he was
swerving on my man in that pic as well I
wish you luck and see the pic smooth now
see how smooth man was holding that
shimmer conception day no was everyone
knows it was off they slipped that rig
on with [ __ ] tonight that's what you
thought over here [ __ ] yeah the wife as
well
oh he had a wife so his daughters away
far from his wife he had a wife when he
was moving to my Nana this is
spin game disgusting game Solomon all
makes sense now the genes were passed on
[ __ ] I'm joking that's hilarious
wow wow wow I like my story match story
very much story do you want to hear my
story you told me yeah the story in it
totally our Conway
[ __ ] sick story said yes so I'm not
gonna name any names obviously
everyone's gonna have an alias yes a any
time frame so normal start thinking when
was this when was this I [ __ ] all that
so I went to link Welsh like what should
I call her we should call these chicks I
don't know if I we use nicknames for a
reason you gave up true true very true
cuz I've saved on my phone as a real
name so I don't even know
show me the name on your [ __ ] phone
and we'll come up to six I think I've
saved though yeah I was willing to run I
mean actually that's her that's her name
you know I'm talking yeah I don't know
let's just call her let's just call her
Becky for now yeah so two six wenter
naked with the good brains Becky with
off with a great brain
[ __ ] if you don't know what brings me
his brains in his head head shines
sloppy top the works all [ __ ] Oh God
fun fact I love head I love great head
who doesn't love head like does it I'm
gonna I'm gonna go off a tangent here
I've always said to people I say I say
it's a better rule actually when we talk
about sex and stuff well as my flatmate
don't get twisted there's a difference
between head and a [ __ ] so in my in
my head
anyone can give a [ __ ] just so yeah
maybe one time you can suck a dick thank
you very much but to give head that's an
art that's an art my good head James
figure out James
we had a love head like there are there
are a few things in life that I love but
good head anyway moving on Becky with a
good brains well that's that's actually
the alias I like it I like it I could be
good bones
Katya Henry whoever name [ __ ] anyway
tangent again so long story short she
came back off holiday and then we were
messing it for ages back on for Paco
because I'd already [ __ ] up right she
went on holiday message me back and
forth back and forth back and forth I am
when I'm gonna see you again Rhetta
tears like oh she's back the x y&z day
will link probably three days later down
the line cuz obviously she got [ __ ] to
not go work rats test so that's when our
schedules aligned I wasn't safe say no
more I worked I think I worked that
night till about midnight and she was
out that night so she got in she was she
was finished from a night from around
two-ish 3ish whatever so I got high with
Bella
so we're eatin chillin whatever and I
was knackered
I was knock about horny because we had
it we had we had already pre-planned
this link I was like cool you know I'm
gonna see it for
Retta - say no more whatever it makes no
difference what you see weapons cool
so she messaged me around I want to say
233 I can remember and I was naked
obviously secured a new body she lives
far by the way she was like 20 minutes
in new bar it was like 20 quid 25 quid 6
it said next me it vex me for sex but it
happens I've done it before anyway some
in uber now I'm high I'm tired and I'm
bloated and I'm like this is a terrible
decision but I think I slept for like
two minutes
and then woke up I was like you know
what I'm actually fine cool god I'm
actually fine cool got out the taxi cuz
but prior to that let me backtrack prior
to that I've only been to my yard once
and that was after the first night we
went out for drinks Bennet's yard once
when I wasn't paying attention to where
I was he said of route because on the
route idiot and brutal yard were just
chatting in a car so but I remember
distinctively her car was parked on the
right of her house and she drives a
white car and I wasn't that caught okay
for some reason I was like I just
remember that was like all got out the
taxi and I was in like a tease on so
obviously it was just bare house you
can't come out of it you can't go
through so I'm I'm high I'm stumbling
stumble in James because the air just
hit me I'm stumbling
taxi driver looks at me and peels off
and he's probably looking at me like
this guy doesn't know where he is and he
just peels off I'm like okay cool I'm
here now I messaged her saying you're
I'm here she's like ah she's about three
minutes away I was like cool and it was
raining so that's a distressed in my
life
it was raining I'm hi I'm in a white
neighborhood I'm in a white neighborhood
it's it's it's it's I mean so I start
walking up to a yard that's got a white
car mmm no no I don't message her I
thought welcome to yard that weather
where there's a white car even though
she's driving in her car currently no so
I'm walking up today
I've set a measure saying I'm outside
yeah where she responded and I'm walking
up to a car a white car with lights on
in the house mm-hmm and then as soon as
I get to about three or four feet to the
car she messaged me saying yeah yeah I'm
still in a taxi my heart James I could
have pulled up to an unknown yard
I mean tracksuits I'm black and I'm in a
white neighborhood and up and up hi
James
the paranoia that's just round one
that's just round one the paranoia that
went through my brain I was like I'm
going to jail I immediately thought I'm
going to jail because it if anyone
watched me do what I did they wouldn't
know I am not from there yeah you
stumbled out the uber and I look like
I'm about to rob someone robbed raping
kill James in your lose track 'yes James
quick slip of the day go out I was
petrified to say the least petrified so
I'm like you need to hurry up don't I
can't remember where you live and you
like just keep walking down you'll see a
yard with two pillars but I'm looking
round and Aquatics I think was behind
sign like behind it she was our car
remember so there was the yard I went to
was on a left light to run the yard
opposite her yard lights were on and it
was another yard lights were on and I'm
thinking yo hurry up hurry up because my
life isn't worthless dude I mean I'm
paranoid because I'm high yeah she bells
me she's like you know what get the keys
because she said she left the keys under
the mat I didn't go into my own I'm like
you're having a bubble if anyone sees me
do this art if they've done seeing me
stumble to a car and stumble back I'm
going to jail I'm going to penitentiary
I'm not doing I'm going for me of course
you don't know what you're saying you're
saying that because you're you're horny
and you're tipsy like you just want to
get you out of yourself
I get way it's coming from a loving
place but imagine it the other way
around like I'm a black man in a white
stumble into different you deep how
scary that is for these made me cough
yes Oh scared
hmm so long story short I found the yard
ok sick I'm dead she's like yeah yeah
the keys underneath the ting found the
key open the door but her parents one
holiday that's okay forgot to even was
thinking first yeah she paid mortgage
for gone I know everyone's thinking
who's in the yard forgot to add it her
parents were holiday so got the key got
into the yard silently because I I don't
know who [ __ ] in there she says where
the [ __ ] your dog then hmm
I'm thinking okay oh my god so get into
the yard I start looking around start
looking around I feel like a burglar but
she's not there she's not there yet
James I feel like I've just be an eID
breaking the Mensch we've done what I
means here be me
I thought come over tracksuit black hi
I bubbled I basically broken and she did
I literally broken in and entered if
anyone saw this or Tate or anything
they're calling five-o
yeah and that's me done yeah understand
they should have the company she'd have
to say sure out use words I don't know
this guy imagine imagine she pulls up to
station B like I don't notice whether
penitentiary died Oh die James I would
use the first phone call bu Oh glove
don't waste your time phone Oh [ __ ]
piss myself I'm not coming up in it
I was petrified and you know what even
makes it worse
she's probably see this anyway which is
weird I was rolling around the yard I'm
just looking at a yard like I was
peeping through windows looking in every
room yeah because the first time I've
gone there we just I think we had a
drink and a wedge straight to a roof so
literally looking around the yard and
redditor and I've found some room in her
dresser she's got bags like expensive
she works from expensive by the fijian I
don't see that before they were hidden
yeah
yeah from compartment it was like damn
you kept that under lock and key so
walking about five minutes to sober me
felt like 20 minutes to hire me so when
I said I was waiting yeah waiting I'm
some [ __ ] nightmare was sunny
I was so not horny anymore so scared she
pulled she brought up she was with my
bread rinse so she said her Brenda to
say in our yard
but her prejudice don't give a [ __ ] that
I'm about to come to smash about doors
in she said uh prejudice don't care are
you sure I should like no yeah yeah I'm
sure
okay so you think about asking if
they're game as well thumb I didn't
think about I didn't know I thought
about her friends thinking about it yeah
but I would never ever break I would
never ever ever broach the topic yeah
lock into the door one of her bedrooms
through the [ __ ] up
they went out out yeah through what time
is this by the way morning anymore like
three big kid for what you mean three I
think I thought was like eleven know if
I'm sure what's your an out no and you
were home I went home you you were wait
yeah you were at home at 3:00 a.m. gone
uber twenty minutes into a white
neighborhood just no but high and dry
she came in was three but I was ready in
an uber let's say I wasn't over from
about two three I don't remember okay
but yes fine I thought you were talking
like 11 ish know if I'm I went to work I
finished work at midnight around
midnight and then I went home
her friend had bread so yeah a Breton
forever so I'd never met her bread you
than I've seen pictures everybody starts
thinking if they're buff I'm about to
message you tomorrow saying James might
have got a alway a four-way I've never
had a threesome
I'm just thrown out I've never saved
ladies of course hallway hallway I would
have been gassed
brav in my job thing is though with the
fork no wait hot for you what yeah
doesn't saying I will fall with a for
ways like its life or us but it's so
dead for the at least one of the chicks
because I don't know one month or one
bit
yeah exactly finger maybe it is when he
sings he's sitting at a restaurant and
he says he's a bomb in a window and
what's the word I'm looking for
that's the level of ease success what is
a bomb winner do I cover it with this
you know I'm talking about you laughs ah
[ __ ] it out but yeah um that was my
story that was gonna tell you about
saving this mine was a completely
different story
I know completely different story
completely different it's so irrelevant
now but basically it's funny because
you'll get it it's relevant because you
said tired but horny
yeah fam recent I don't know why
sometimes I have this habit where like
if I'm asleep I can wake up in the I
don't know if I'm dreaming or what or if
I'm half asleep or what but sometimes I
can wake up with a hard Oh be [ __ ]
careful please sorry [ __ ] hard dick
like no but like I'm hot like I'm blind
Hornet um like I'm seeing red like I
need to [ __ ] obviously doesn't happen
when I'm by myself because that's just
weird
hmm but like that's what I think I must
be half as heat because I know there's a
[ __ ] into bed yeah so I get the day I
woke up sometimes I usually I can wake
up go through the bit of the motions of
a feel hear feel they're not my [ __ ]
I'll come back to sleep back on so tight
from this night it was a different story
so so I must the woke up right picture
this officer I'm leaving it pays there
mmm I'm just I'm just kidding and then
foxy woke up [ __ ] woke up [ __ ]
horny so from horny horny
yeah like pre-cum horny that's worn his
red pop Horner Bob horny woke up [ __ ]
Jones in fact and I was a sight I need
to not but you know in like ah so stupid
you know when you're in the mindset
where you just sound
[Laughter]
you think he's gonna be working it
that's how I felt did you feel an alum
Sun reach around now and she's just like
BAM she's obviously down like girls and
girls are down to be working up by dick
Yeah right
I'm not down to be working for [ __ ] I
am but like I have to know how to not do
anything so yeah yeah
such a bastard from when I say I work
huh reach around click T neck elope all
that talk firm so funny it must have
grabbed a hand
so she's facing away yeah grab their
hand and in my head I was like obviously
I want to [ __ ] but I don't want to do
anything because I'm still kind of half
asleep yeah and it's like I don't really
want to do anything I don't really yeah
I don't want to move to [ __ ] my need to
not yeah I don't that's the thing I
don't think I wanted to [ __ ] I just want
to know I want to bust up a recent grad
man dick she's I game but she's asleep
them so obviously she's just like
bashing man from behind yeah and I'm
like and I'm thinking up I'm thinking I
went head or even take a good
old-fashioned bash yeah so she's bashing
she bashed it and I'm my right and needs
not now
yeah I'm one head yeah fam yes obvious
I'm still doing the lips in I'm stood in
the everything every yeah yeah and I'm
trying to twist her over in it to face
me but she's knackered as well so she's
like I'm as I'm putting on she's put it
away from me I can feel the resistance
so but obviously you can't make it base
you can't say I want to turn over
she woke me up or [ __ ] of got to
suck your dick
it wears all of it so we're just
argument so after I have to swerve it so
obviously should resist it mana for so
gave it a second more let more load more
firm try it again yeah
tried to angle the ting again she went
having it her neck twisted all the way
around but is it moving it is she's
still battered fair on the third attempt
this is [ __ ] hilarious on the third
attempt I finally tried to twist it
she'd given up she knew what I this what
she knew what I wanted it she knew I
didn't wanna do [ __ ] she randomly grab
the dick sure shoved it in there rubbed
and Shop rub and shoved and what once it
she knows the trick because once it I'm
awake in the [ __ ] game rags fans and
obviously she got me she waited
we should probably doing cuz I'm not
quick but yeah night kit but it was
funny I was funny cuz the perspective
fam is that she knew exactly what I'm
sayin she this [ __ ] was head he doesn't
wanna do nothing it was the wake me up
and not do [ __ ] yeah yeah she knew the
game she sussed it [ __ ] so still
hilarious is there like a frequent flyer
story any you can't do it something you
just like you know smell yeah hundred
percent not 100% that has to be someone
you know
mmm-hmm comfortably no [ __ ] you know
that's hilarious I was writing a list of
[ __ ] to say mmm
to me I just read one so tinder yeah so
I first used tinder hold that thought
all my other juice
yah cracka Rock is 7 7 2008 mines it is
in a freezer
Oh is it not I know I use my teeth you
say that every year
that they go on tinder use first started
using tinder sign say our first time
using tinder a time in my life I'm not
gonna say the time frame and I thought
I've told you before but you won't
remember you won't remember until I say
sign you'll clock so swipe and swipe and
swipe in matchwood it sing actually
don't remember a name we'll talk in and
conversation was going much better than
expected like she was just down from the
offset and this is like I'd never used
tender before
I'll go first experience blah blah but
have sad hurt tinder was good just meet
up be and just be calm and I've gone
nuts about that as well in a second if
it's one time and I'm thinking you know
what conversation flow in and she's bar
mmm but my kind of buff but you know the
kind of girls I like mm thick mm thick
and full [ __ ]
so yeah combo was flowing calm was
flowing and I was looking through her
pictures on $10 comments and saying oh
you know puffin this one but that one
right sir she was local she was about
for a bit cuz she said she's got work up
here for a few for a few a few weeks or
cyanide I was like okay cool
so when should we link when should be
linked she's like oh x y&z day after
work I'm free I'm staying in a hotel we
can link I was like cool I think couple
days before that mmm she asked me to
follow on Instagram I think mm-hmm I was
liking a few pics I said unlike this one
I like that one right
I feel like she even responded saying oh
yeah you said you like that with you
like I was like yeah of course like that
both pictures red-letter cool calm seems
come flowing conversations playing
conversing exploding
obviously I've added on istagram she
didn't put she didn't add me back I was
like you know what is everybody can [ __ ]
about that that much and I think the day
of the day before the link
she wasn't active so I think I sent her
something that come over was she
responds okay cool weather his what is
the day of the link and finished work a
holiday like yo so what's the plan red
tutor
we gotta meet art I should respond I was
like cool and I just left the note I
didn't just leave it I definitely triple
or quadruple message I was like it needs
to happen yes the [ __ ] yeah yeah
obviously he didn't happen it didn't
happen
I think days went by days went by and
then she's posting a few stories on
Instagram and then it comes up with her
tinder thing or so I thought and she was
like this isn't me whoever this is god
that's [ __ ] hilarious that was my
first catfish experience I was gutted
I've no been so proud of my life
I got playful for like first of all you
man that catfish why telamonian you're
willing to link Doug so what if I wrote
on the spot you found dead what'd you
get raped and killed raped by a guy um
it might this is the trouble omits in
Doug women think it's just a minute we
don't think they're the only ones in
trouble if you get catfished by big man
dark skinned
I don't know why it's just more thread
dark-skinned threads
six-six oh my god and you go around the
yard you might tell me yeah and as I
think a girl will plan a hit yeah thank
you for goes randomly come into the
house she probably told three of her
friends and said this is the address if
you don't hear from me in the next four
hours call some 100% dude you gonna do
that no I'm rolling up to you and with
confidence comes condoms and confidence
what's up asana yeah you say bang and
then that's it
night it we're good now be like gang
brother if you get catfished and my
man's like yeah yeah yeah 64 Elm come
through at 11 yeah I'll be wearing this
and sounds like a ranch pick you roll
through
you don't seem twice my man answered the
door
well the Gundy heads is gained house
just so you can't run get out from those
screen get a [ __ ] house phone
guessing in the room says get stark
naked what do you do get started naked
he leaves his top on takes his jeans off
[Music]
that's right that's right these digs
these are top on takes jeans off and his
shoes on shoes and socks on sweats come
off English didn't you iron get get
naked his guns doing this handshake it
sounds [ __ ] shaking look take it now
lay in your belly and get a [ __ ] naked
what do you do I have to get naked I'm
not getting my blue I'm not getting a
head blown off I'm not dying is the
foremost I'd never want to get raped
I didn't run my ass get in touch no one
wants to get ready for [ __ ] Hamas
kids are the same same what what is the
thrill of a girl like in a guy what is
that of a girl naked the guy's ass
yuck a lot of girls have asked me a lot
a lot a lot of girls have asked me what
if they can if they can fast
g-spot chat they don't talk to me like
you know me don't talk to me like you
know mine at me I just we nice fine it's
cozy it's dormant right she spies
doorman every I don't need any of that
bro I need my geez what like I need my
[ __ ] tonsils sharp not affecting
anyone mine in their business innit my
g-spot be [ __ ] me I'm swayed from tinder
just from tinder women aren't in danger
we are that's the truth women are in
danger we are tender is the devil's
playground catfish is easy on tinder
we've got to do is make a Facebook page
right easy still anyone's pictures
obviously you just never post a story
that's wild I've imagined so people know
I think you've gone
brav - Gary imagine any question yeah no
there's no option for it to be a known
situation thing okay so would you rather
you have to pick one you have to have
four by this before you have to pick one
before you say the would you rub you
putting a group try that time dying I
remember - what about the man would you
would you I think you said 400 mil would
you get back showered no 450 750 ml
would you let guy [ __ ] you 100 me would
ya guy [ __ ] you and lips you say cos I
did tell him and loves him in yoruba I
can never get lips by a man this is this
is this is very relative to that [ __ ]
you know so would you rather mmm a guy
like literally you just
Rough Rider and bang II did she just
hey head in the pillow shut your mouth
bangs you Tilley nuts and just [ __ ]
walks out [ __ ] you know yeah oh he never
once penetrates you b-but he treats you
like his girlfriend like his actual girl
he thinks you're his girlfriend and he's
like grubby shoots
bites her lip licks your neck licks your
tit [ __ ] like tickles your [ __ ] like
he brings her she clear now but he never
once got printers rates you know what
nuns room never once enters you be treat
you like a woman like a beautiful
[ __ ] woman ok let's talk let's talk
timeframes so I see if I'm getting
penetrated any nuts
it's only gonna last so long it's a
seven minute night and it's a seven
minute foreplay oh seven minutes I can't
get penetrated seven minutes I can't get
penetrated four seven no four minutes
that's long fur I know it's long long
ages penetrate rough like rough bang
bang bang bang four minutes but you get
to convince yourself that you're still a
man in it he gets it just don't even
hurt bro calm
then ones you know once they get a tough
[ __ ] think of happy thoughts but with
the other one you have to look him in
his eye and he squeezes yoongi lips is
me puts his fingers in your mouth
this makes you suck his fingers like
bites you lips suck [ __ ] earlobe for
four minutes squeezes your our
spreadsheet cheeks everything that you
pinches in nipple and twists it
everything that you do to a girl just to
you pick one you have to pick one I have
to pick one
I just can't get penetrated I'm sorry I
have to pick the first one
I'm getting banged you came back
propably for four minutes
rough probably a no probably bleeding
I'll believe them I'll be for it I'll
bleed for it there's no way in hell
there's only [ __ ] hell I'm looking at
a guy in his eye while he makes love to
me like mix their bee doesn't penetrate
but he makes love to me fam he creates
love fam creates love I can't get banged
and his penis is on my stomach it's
everywhere else is a deacon ago my legs
are spread
oh he's inside like he's inside my leg
gate everything he's not [ __ ] me but
we make it love I'm not doing that cuz
that's mental I can't recover from
four minutes I'll pretend I'm just
getting beat up I'll pretend I'm just
crying yeah same same I know it's gonna
hurt but I know it's gonna [ __ ] hurt
but I will take it foul and I'll just
Fermi and I'll be like I'm still gang
these my I can't break me I'll be in my
head that he's [ __ ] bout to break me I
won't let it break me I won't break me
just finish your [ __ ] thing and let
me go from four minutes of squeezing
more cheese give me this thing the
slapping tink now slaps the dick on my
belly then once like before I press it
in crazy his tongue is in your in your
mouth
I'm swaying he says open your [ __ ]
mouth puts his fingers in there touches
the gag on it are you nuts
no I can't
honest I've got a con she's [ __ ]
quite as I can't pay anyway I think we
need to wrap this up we do we need to
get to dinner [ __ ] it all that was funny
it was that was funny